[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: So
welcome, everybody.
Welcome back.
Let's get started
with today's lecture.
Where were we?
On Tuesday, we
covered, the main topic
was the recursion theorem,
which allows programs
to self-reference.
And we saw some
applications of that, too.
So we gave a new proof
that ATM is undecidable.
We looked at this language
of minimal Turing machine
descriptions.
And we had a short digression
into mathematical logic,
where we looked at how
one shows that there
are true, but
unprovable, statements
in any reasonable formal system.
So today, we're going
to shift gears entirely.
And we're moving into the
second half of the course, where
we are beginning a study
of computational complexity
theory.
And we'll say a
little bit about that
during the course of
the lecture, of course.
But the main things
that we are going
to cover in terms of
content that you will need
is defining the complexity
classes and the class P.
And we'll prove a few
theorems along the way.
But that's the main
objective of today's lecture.
Computability theory, which was
the subject of the first half
of the course, and which is
what the midterm exam is going
to cover, was a subject
that was an active area
of mathematical study in the
first part of the 20th century.
It really got-- it
really dates back
into the late 19th
century, in fact,
when people were trying to
figure out how to formalize
mathematical reasoning.
But it really got
going in the 1930s
with the work of Godel,
and Church, and Turing,
who really formalized
for the first time what
we mean by algorithm.
And that allowed the study
of algorithms to really get
started.
And it had its impact,
as I mentioned,
on the actual design,
building, and thinking
about real computers.
The main question, if you
kind of boil the subject
down to a single question, is
some language decidable or not.
In complexity theory,
which got started
kind of when computability
theory more or less wrapped up
as a subject, largely
because they answered many
of the questions that they--
they answered pretty much all
of the questions that
they were asking.
So there really aren't
interesting unsolved questions
left in that field.
And you really need
mathematical questions
to keep a subject alive,
unsolved questions.
So complexity theory got
its start in the 1960s.
And it continues on as an
active area of research
to the present day.
And I guess if you
could boil it down,
it would be is a language
decidable with some restriction
on the resources, such
as the amount of time,
or memory, or some other--
or some other kinds of resources
that you might provide,
randomness, and so on?
All of those are within the
area of computational complexity
theory.
So let's get ourselves
started with an example.
Here is the language that
we've looked at in the past, a
to the k, b to the k.
And let's look at it now from
the perspective of complexity.
All of the languages
that we're going
to be studying in
complexity are all
going to be decidable languages.
So the question
of undecidability
in complexity theory is
not really of interest.
It's all decidable
languages, but the question
is how decidable.
What sort of resources do
you need to do the deciding?
So for this language A,
how many steps are needed?
Well, we're going to spend
a little time just kind
of setting up the
definitions of the subject
and kind of motivating them.
So for this language A, when I
ask how many steps are needed,
well, it's going to depend upon
which input you have in mind.
Some inputs might require
more steps than others.
So the way we're going
to set the subject up,
which is the standard way
that people in this field
look at it, and I think that
applies to lots of examples
outside as well,
is that we're going
to kind of group all of the
inputs of the same length
together.
And look at the maximum cost,
the maximum number of steps
you need, to solve any one of
those inputs of a given length.
And we'll do that
for each length.
And the way we're
going to frame it
is in terms of giving
a maximum, or what's
called an upper bound, on
the amount of time that you
need to solve all of
those inputs of length n.
That's what's sometimes
called worst-case complexity.
I'm sure many of you
seen this already.
But just to make sure
we're all together on this,
you might contrast
that, for example,
with what's called
average case complexity.
Where instead of looking
at the most difficult case
among all inputs
of length n, you
take the average of
all inputs of length n.
And then you have to--
then it's a little bit more
complicated, because
then you need
to have a probability
distribution on those inputs
and so on.
We're not going to look
at it, in this course,
from that perspective.
We're only going to
be looking at what's
called worst-case complexity.
So let's begin, then, by
looking at this in more detail
and taking as our
starting point the theorem
that says that on a one
tape Turing machine, which
is deciding this language
A, a to the k, b to the k,
you can do this on a one
tape Turing machine, M,
we're calling it.
In at most some constant
times n squared steps,
for any input of length n,
where the constant is going
to be fixed independent of it.
So this is going to be--
having a constant in--
factor in the complexity
is going to come up often.
And so instead of saying
this over and over again,
we're going to use
a notation that m
uses order n squared steps.
I'm sure many of you seen
that terminology as well.
But just for the
purposes of making
sure we're all
together on that, there
is this big O and
little o notation.
I'm expecting you to
be familiar with that.
Big O is when you apply to
functions, as it's done.
You say f is big O of g, as
for two functions f and g.
It's basically if f is
less than or equal to g,
if you're ignoring
constant factors.
And you say f is little o of
g if f is strictly less than g
if you're ignoring
constant factors.
That's kind of one sort of
informal way of looking at it.
The precise definition is
given up there on the slide.
And if you haven't
seen it before,
make sure you look
at it in the book,
where it's all carefully
described and defined.
So that you're comfortable
with these notions.
Because it's
really-- we're going
to be using this without
any further discussion
from here on.
So let's get to the proof,
then, of this theorem
that you can do the language
A in order n squared steps.
Not super hard.
I think if I asked you to
come up with an algorithm
to solve A, this
would be the algorithm
that you would find basically.
First, you would start off by
scanning the input w to make
sure it's of the right form.
So a run of a's followed by
a run of b's of some lengths.
And if it's not of
that form, then you're
going to reject right away.
The next thing you'll do
is then go to a repeat
loop in the Turing machine.
And if you imagine, here is your
machine, here is the input w,
you're going to go through
that repeating repeatedly.
Of course, you can do this in
a number of different ways.
But here's the way I have in
mind for you, on this slide,
anyway.
We're going to scan
the entire tape,
crossing off a single a
and a single b on a scan.
And then you're going to
keep doing that until you've
crossed off everything.
Unless you run out of a's
or you run out of b's.
In that case, you're
going to reject.
If you run out of a's or
b's before you run out
of the other type, then you
know that you started out
with an unequal number.
And so the machine
is going to reject.
If you've managed to cross them
all off without running out
of one before the other,
then you'll accept.
I know this is kind of obvious.
But I think it's important to
get us all together on this
at the beginning.
So here's a little animation of
the Turing machine doing that.
I'm not showing the
motion of the head.
But you imagine the head
scanning back and forth,
crossing off these a's and b's,
one a and one b on each pass,
until they're all crossed off.
And then it accepts.
Unless of course, it
runs out of a's or b's
before the other
type, then it rejects.
OK, now let's do a very quick,
informal analysis of how
much time this has taken.
So the very first stage, I'm
calling each of these things
stages of the Turing
machine to distinguish them
from the steps of
the Turing machine,
which are the individual
transition function moves.
So this is the entire
stage of the machine.
The very first stage
takes order n steps,
because you have to make
a scan across the input.
And then I'm not giving
all the full detail.
Of course, you're
going to scan and then
you're going to return the head
back to its starting position.
I'm not-- that's just going
to be an extra factor of n,
an extra n.
And so that's where we're
talking about being order n
steps for the very first stage.
And then as you go
through the repeat
loop, each time you go
through the repeat loop,
you're going to cross
off one a and one b.
So that's going to mean you're
going to have to do this
roughly order-- you're going
have to do this order n times
in order to cross off
all the a's and b's.
So there's going to be order n
iterations of this repeat loop.
Each one of them is going
to, again, require a scan.
So that's order n steps for
each one of the iterations.
So adding that all up, the very
top row gives us the order n
and then we have the
order n iterations
times order n steps is
order n squared steps.
And so the sum of
these two is order n
squared steps due to
the nature of arithmetic
when you have the
big O notation.
The dominant term overrides
all of the others.
So that's, in a
nutshell, how we--
well, this is our
very first example
of analyzing the Turing machine
algorithm for a language.
So let me ask you now whether
there is some other Turing
machine, some other one
tape Turing machine which
can do better than this
Turing machine does in terms
of how much time it takes.
So one idea that you might
have, instead of crossing off
a single a or a single b,
maybe you can cross off two
a's and two b's, or
10 a's and 10 b's.
Well, that'll cut down the
running time by a factor of 10.
But from the standpoint
of this theorem,
it's still going to be an
order n squared algorithm.
And so that really doesn't
change the amount of time
used from the perspective of--
from our perspective,
where we're
going to be ignoring the
constant factors on the running
time.
So I ask you here,
can you do better
than just improving things
by a constant factor?
There we go.
OK, so here's a check-in on
this problem, on the problem A,
deciding A on a one
tape Turing machine.
Can we do better
than order n squared,
as I just described
in that theorem
in that algorithm
for that theorem?
Or can you get it
down to n log n?
Or maybe you can get
it down to order n?
What do you think?
Obviously, we're
just getting started.
But just make your best guess.
And let me just post
that for you as a poll.
What's most important to
me is that you understand
the terminology that we're
using and the way we're
discussing-- the way
we're talking about it.
Because that's going
to be setting us
up for the
definitions that we're
going to come a little
bit later in the lecture.
So I'm going to close the poll.
We're kind of all
over the place on it.
But that's good.
Since we haven't really
covered this material yet.
In fact, B is the
correct answer.
We can improve this algorithm
down to order n log n,
but not all the way
down to order n.
So let me give-- let me show
you how you do it in order n log
n on the next slide.
And so here is a one
tape Turing machine
that can decide A by using only
order n log n steps instead
of order n squared steps.
So this is a
significant improvement.
So I'll describe
the Turing machine.
Here, again, is the picture
of the machine on an input.
And the very first
thing I need to say
is that we're going to scan
to make sure the input is
of the right form.
And now, we're going
to-- again, it's
going to be making repeated
passes over the input.
But we're going to do it
a little differently now.
Instead of crossing off a
single a and a single b,
or some fixed number of a's and
a fixed number of b's, we're
going to cross off every
other a and every other b.
And that way, we're
going to essentially cut
the number of a and b in half.
And that's why the
number of iterations
is only going to be a
log, instead of linear.
So we're going to
cross off every other a
and every other b.
And at the same
time, we're going
to keep track of the
parity, the even/odd parity
of the number of
a's that we've seen
and the parity of
the number of b's
that we've seen that have
not yet been crossed off.
And we're going to compare
those parities to make sure
that they agree.
If they ever disagree, we know
we started off with different
numbers of a's and b's.
And I'll illustrate
this in a second,
just to make sure we
understand this algorithm.
So I'm going to write down as
a little table of the parities
that we've seen.
And I'm going to
illustrate the algorithm
with a little animation.
So again, we're now
going to scan across,
crossing off every other
a, and then every other b.
But before we get to the b's, we
observe, as we cross these off,
that we had six a's.
Now, I'm not saying
we count them.
We just keep track of
the even/odd parity.
That can be done in the
finite control of the machine.
Counting them would
be more complicated.
But just keeping
track of the parity
is something that the
finite automaton could do.
So the parity in this case,
because they were six,
is going to be even.
Now, we cross off the b's.
Same, even parity, now we're
going to return the head back
to the beginning, I'm
obviously not showing
the head moving here.
We return the head
back to the beginning.
And now, we scan across,
again, crossing off every other
remaining a and counting the
parities of the remaining a's.
So here now, it's
going to be this one
and this one are going
to get crossed off.
And there were three a's,
so that was odd parity.
And the same for the b's,
three b's, odd parity.
And now we return our head
back to the beginning,
cross again, off every
other a and every other b.
So that was odd parity,
there was just one.
Crossing off the b, odd
parity because just one.
They all agree.
So the machine is
going to accept.
Because everything
is now crossed off.
And the parities
agreed along the way.
Let me just say for
a second, obviously,
if you ever get disagreement
on the parities,
then that the number of
a's and the number of b's
had to disagree.
But how do we know that if the
parities always agree that we
actually did start out with
the same number of a's as b's?
And that, you could see that
in a number of different ways,
but perhaps a cute way to
see it is there is actually--
if you look at these parities ,
here the sequence of parities,
actually in reverse.
So if you say odd,
odd, even, and you
look at the binary
representation
of the number of
a's, which is six,
so the binary
representation would be 110.
The fact that you
get odd, odd, even
and 110 is not a coincidence.
In fact, the sequence
of parities in reverse
that you get is exactly the same
as the binary representation.
You'd have to confirm
that with a little proof.
It's not hard.
But that, once
you have confirmed
that, you can see that if the
sequence of parities agree,
then the numbers
have to be the same,
because the binary
representations agreed.
OK, so now getting
to the analysis here,
again, order n steps
to do the check.
Log n iterations.
Each scan takes order n steps.
So the total running time here
is going to be order n log n.
It's going to be
the log n times n.
That's where the n
log n comes from.
Now, question you
might ask, could I
do even better than that?
Can I beat n log n by more
than any constant factor?
So can I do little o of n log n?
And the answer is no.
This is the best
possible one tape Turing
machine for this language.
So a one tape Turing machine
cannot decide A by using little
o of n log n steps.
We're not going to prove that.
I'm not going to ask you to
be responsible for the proof.
But in fact, what
you can show is
that any language that you can
do on a one tape Turing machine
in the little o of n log n
steps turns out to be regular.
So you can prove a
rather strong theme here.
Not super difficult to prove.
But I don't want to
spend a lot of time
on proving grounds
for Turing machines.
Because really the whole
purpose of setting this up
using Turing machines is to talk
about algorithms in general,
algorithms in
general, I'm not going
to be focusing on the nitty
gritty of Turing machines.
OK so what is my--
yeah, so I wanted to
just stop and make
sure that we are together here.
So a brief pause.
And feel free to send
me any questions.
OK, this is a good question.
If we can keep
track of parities,
why can't we just keep track
of the number of a's or b's?
Well, you could keep
track of the parity
in the finite memory.
And so you can do that
with effectively no work.
But the finite memory cannot is
not enough for doing a count up
to some arbitrarily
large number.
Now, you could store
the count on the tape.
But that's going to cost you
time to maintain that counter.
And so that's not going
to be so simple as keeping
track of the parity
in the finite memory.
Somebody is asking if a
star b star is regular.
Yes, a star b star is regular.
So what?
But a to the k, b to the
k, which is our language,
is not regular.
That's the language
we're looking at.
So getting questions about what
happens with multiple tapes.
We'll talk about
that in a second.
Yes, we could do an order n
steps on a regular computer,
sure.
But for this slide,
anyway, we're
looking at one tape
Turing machines.
Getting questions about
big O and little o.
For something to
be little o means
it's less than any constant
factor times the function.
So you have to look at the
definition in the book.
I think enough
people in the class
probably know this and
have seen this already,
I don't want to spend
everybody's time on it.
But please review
it in the book.
Somebody is asking
if you need to store
the parity on the tape.
No, you can just store
it in the finite memory.
I mean, storing in the
finite memory seems to me
the simplest thing.
Why don't we move on?
Please feel free to ask
questions to the TAs as well.
We have two TAs at least
here attending with me.
So good, all right, all right,
so we cannot do better than
a one tape Turing machine-- on
a one tape Turing machine than
order n log n.
And that's something
we can prove,
though we're not
going to do it here.
However, if you change the
model, for example, you
use a two tape Turing machine,
then yes, as a lot of you
are suggesting in the chat,
you can do better than that.
So if we now have
a two tape Turing
machine, or a multi-tape
Turing machine,
you can do it in order n steps.
And that's actually the point
I'm really trying to make here.
So if you have here your
two tape Turing machine,
then two tapes, same language.
Now, what we're
going to do is copy
the a's to the second tape.
That we can do on a single pass.
And then once the a's have
been copied to the second tape,
we can continue on reading
the b's and match them off
with the a's that appear
on the second tape.
So in order n steps, you
can do the comparison,
instead of order n log n steps.
And of course, if
they match, you're
going to accept,
otherwise reject.
So let's just see,
here's a little animation
demonstrating that.
Of course, it's very simple.
So here is-- here are the--
if you could see that,
it came maybe a little too fast.
Here, let's just show it again.
Here is the heads moving
across and the a's
coming down to the bottom.
And now, the head, the upper
head is going to continue
on reading the b's.
The lower head is going to
go back to the beginning
on the a's and matching
off the b's with the a's.
And that's how we
can verify or check
that they are the same number.
So now in this case, they
were the same number.
So the machine would accept.
If they were a different number,
the machine would not accept.
And the analysis is very simple.
Each stage here is going to
take a linear number of steps,
order n steps, because it just
consists of a single scan.
There are no-- there are
no loops in this machine,
no repeat loops.
So question on this?
All right, why don't
we move on then?
Now, observe-- and the point
I'm really trying to make
is that on a one
tape Turing machine,
you can do it in n log
n, but not any better.
But on a two tape
Turing machine,
you can do it in order n.
So there's a difference
in how much time you
need to spend, how many
steps you need to spend,
depending upon the model.
And that's significant for us.
So the number of steps
depends on the model.
One tape Turing machine was
order n log n, multi-tape
was order n.
We call that model dependence.
If you contrast that with the
situation in the complexity--
in the computability
section of the course,
we had model independence.
The choice of the
model didn't matter.
And that was nice for us.
Because the theory
of the decidability
didn't depend upon whether
you had a one tape Turing
machine, or a multi-tape
Turing machine,
it was all the same set of
decidable and recognizable
languages.
So we didn't have to
worry about which model
we're actually
going to work with.
We could work with
any model, even just
an informal model of algorithm
would be good enough.
Because we're going to end
up with the same notion
in the end.
Now that goes away
in complexity theory.
Now, we have a difference,
depending upon the model.
And from a mathematical
standpoint,
that's a little less nice.
Because which model
do you work with?
If you want to understand the
complexity of some problem
that you have at hand, now
you have to make a choice.
You're going to work
with a Turing machine,
or how many tapes,
or you're going
to look at some other
model, and you're
going to get different results.
So it's somewhat less natural
from a mathematical standpoint
just to talk about the
complexity of some problem.
But we're going to kind of bring
back something close enough
to model independence by
observing that even though we
don't have model
independence, as we did
in computability theory, we can
limit how much dependence there
is.
So the amount of
dependence is going
to be low, as we
will see, provided
you stick with a reasonable
class of deterministic models.
So the dependence,
though it does exist,
is not going to be that much.
It's going to be
polynomial dependence.
And we'll say exactly what
that means in a second.
And from our
standpoint, that's going
to be a small difference,
a negligible difference
that we're going to ignore.
So we're going to focus
on questions that do not
depend on the model choice among
these reasonable deterministic
models.
Now, you may say,
well, that's not
interesting from a
practical standpoint,
because polynomial differences,
say the difference between n
squared and n cubed certainly
make a difference in practice.
But it really depends on
what kinds of questions
you're focusing on.
So if you want to look
at something that's
a very precise distinction, say
between n squared and n cubed,
then you might want to
focus in on which model
you want to be working with.
And that's going to be more the
domain of an algorithms class.
But from our
standpoint, we're going
to be looking at other,
still important, questions.
But they are questions that
don't depend upon exactly
which polynomial
you're going to have.
We're going to be looking
more at distinctions
between polynomial
and exponential.
And still, there are
important practical questions
that arise in that
somewhat different setting.
So with that in
mind, we're going
to continue to use
the one tape Turing
machine as our basic
model of complexity.
Since the model among the
reasonable deterministic models
in the end is not
going to matter
from the perspective of
the kinds of questions
we're going to be asking.
So with that, so we
are going to continue,
then, it's important to remember
that from going forward,
we're going to stick with the
one tape Turing machine model.
Maybe that's something you would
have expected us to do anyway.
But I'm trying to justify that
through this little discussion
that we had so far, thus far.
So now, we're going to start
defining things with the one
tape model in mind.
So first of all, if you
have a Turing machine,
we're going to say it runs
in a certain amount of time.
So if t is some sort of time
bound function, like n squared,
or n log n, we'll
say the machine runs
in that amount of time,
like n squared or n log n.
if that machine M always halts
within that number of steps
on all inputs of length n.
So it always halts within t of
n steps on inputs of length n.
Then we'll say that the
machine runs in t of n time.
So in other words, if the
machine runs in n squared time,
then the machine, when you
give it an input of length 10,
it's got to be
guaranteed to halt
within 100 steps, 10
squared, 100 steps,
on every input of length 10.
That's what it means
for the machine
to be running in that much time.
And it has to do that for every
n, for every input length.
And width that, we're going
to come to the following
definition, which is highlighted
in color, because it's
going to be--
we're going to be
using this definition
throughout the semester.
So it's important
to understand it.
This is the definition of what's
called the time complexity
classes.
And what I'm going to do
is take some bound, t of n,
and again, think of t of n
like a bound like n squared.
So if you have time t of
n or like time n squared,
that's going to be the
collection of all languages
that you can decide
within time n squared
or within time t of n.
So in other words, it's a
collection of all languages B
such that there's some
one tape Turing machine,
here we're focusing again on
the one tape Turing machine,
there is some deterministic
one tape Turing
machine that decides
B. And that machine
runs in that amount of time.
So this is a collection
of languages.
The time complexity class
is a set of languages.
I'm going to draw
it now as a diagram.
So if you take the
language, again,
that we've been using as our
standard example, a to the k,
b to the k, that's
n time n log n,
as we observed two
slides to slides back,
or three slides back.
So on a one tape Turing machine,
you can do this language A
in time n log n.
So it's in the time
complexity class n log n.
This region here captures
all of the languages
that you can do in
order n log n time.
For example, that also includes
all of the regular languages.
Why is that?
Well, any regular language can
be done on a one tape Turing
machine in time order n, because
the Turing machine only just
needs to scan across.
Doesn't even need to write, just
need to scan across from left
to right on the tape.
And in n steps,
it has the answer.
So all of the regular
languages are actually in time
n, certainly a subset
of time n log n.
And these all form a
kind of a hierarchy.
So if you increase
the bound, you
can imagine that the
class of languages
grows as you allow the machine
to have more and more steps
to do its computing.
So these are all the languages
that you can do in n squared,
order n squared time on a
one tape Turing machine,
n cubed time on a one
tape Turing machine,
and so on, 2 exponential time,
2 to the n time on a one tape
Turing machine.
These are all
collections of languages
getting larger and larger
as we increase the bound.
So someone is asking kind of--
let's see, let me get to
some of these questions here.
I'll try to get
to them in order.
So somebody says if you have--
a good question, if you
have a regular computer, so
an ordinary sort of
random access computer,
which we'll talk about that in
a second, can do it in order n,
can you do it on a
multi-tape Turing machine
also in order n time?
Actually, I don't know the
answer to that offhand.
I suspect the answer is no.
That ordinary computers have
a random access capability
that Turing machines do not.
And so that there are going to
be some examples of problems
that you can do with a random--
with a regular computer that you
cannot do with the multi-tape
Turing machine in order n time.
I'd have to double check
that, though, so we can--
it's also a question
what we believe is true
and what we can
prove to be true.
As we'll see, there
are a lot of things
that we believe to be
true in this subject
that we don't know how to prove.
Somebody is asking kind
of an interesting sort
of more advanced question.
Is there some function
f, some function t
where it's so big that
so that time t of n
gives you all of the
decidable problems?
It would be a very big t.
But the answer actually
to that question is yes.
But that's a little bit exotic.
So let's not spend a lot
of time on that right here.
But happy to talk
about that offline.
It's a good question here.
Somebody's asking
me does it mean
that there are no languages
between order n and order n log
n, because I pointed out
that anything below n log n
is going to be regular.
And so, as soon as
you get below n log n,
you can do it in order n.
And yes, there is what's
called a gap between order n
and order n log n on a
one tape Turing machine.
You don't get anything new
from order n until you jump up.
So from order n to order n log
log n, nothing new shows up.
So we'll talk about those kinds
of things a little bit down
the road, when we look at
actually the relationship
among these various classes,
and what we call a hierarchy
theorem, which shows--
how much bigger do you have
to make the bound in order
to be sure you'll
get something new?
All right, somebody's
asking is there
a model which has the
same time complexity
as a normal computer?
Well, I mean, there's
the random access model,
which is supposed to
capture a normal computer.
So let me-- these are
all great questions, kind
of more riffing off of this
into more advanced directions.
Let's move on.
Here's another check-in.
Suppose we take-- this is a
little bit of a check to see
how well--
how comfortable you are with
the notions we've just presented
and whether you can think
about some of the arguments
that we've made and apply
them to a new language.
So take the language ww reverse,
strings followed by their--
followed by
themselves backwards.
This language B are the
even length palindromes,
if you will.
What's the smallest
bound that you
need to be able to
solve that language B?
And I'll pose it as a--
pose that as a question for you.
So which time complexity
class is that language B in?
Is it time order n, order
n log n, n squared, so on?
What do you think?
So we're about to come
to the coffee break.
So why don't we--
I'll answer any
questions that come up.
I think we're got
everybody answered.
So I'm going to end the polling.
OK, make sure you're in
if you want to be in.
So the correct answer is,
in fact, order n squared.
It would be hard--
reasonable guess here
would be order n log n.
I mean, you can come up
with the same procedure
as the one we showed
at the beginning,
the order n squared procedure
for a to the k, b to the k
works for ww reverse as well.
You can just cross off,
sweep back and forth,
crossing off a symbol
from w, and going across
to the other side, crossing
off a symbol from w reverse.
And that procedure will give
you an n squared and order
n squared algorithm.
You might imagine you can
improve it to order n log n.
But you cannot.
You can prove that order n
squared is the best possible.
I'm a little unhappy that a lot
of you came up with order n,
frankly.
Because I already told
you that order n is--
these are just
regular languages.
Anything that you
can do in less than--
a little o of n log n
is going to be regular.
And we know this
language is not regular.
So this was not a good answer.
So please pay attention.
And OK, so let us stop sharing.
I will turn now to our
break for five minutes.
And I'm happy to try to
take questions along the way
as we're waiting
for the time to end.
So let's see, let
me put this up here.
Let me try to take
some of your questions.
So someone is asking me
about quantum computers
as reasonable models of--
you may say a quantum
computer is a reasonable model
of computation.
And that's fine.
I would not say it's
a reasonable model
of deterministic computation,
at least from our standpoint.
Let's not quibble
about the words.
I'm not including
quantum computers
in the collection of machines
that I have in mind right now
when I'm talking about
the reasonable models
of deterministic
computation that we're
going to be discussing.
Let's see.
Oh, because a bunch
of people apparently
are asking the TAs why
all regular languages can
be done in order n.
So if you think
about a DFA, which
processes an input of
length n with n steps,
and a DFA is I'm going to
be a type of Turing machine
that never writes on its
tape, so if a DFA can do it
in n steps, the Turing
machine can do it in n steps.
And so therefore,
every regular language
can be done in order n
steps on a Turing machine.
Not sure where the confusion is.
So please message me if
you're still not getting it.
OK, somebody saying why are we
using one tape Turing machines
instead of random access?
Wouldn't it be better to use
the random access machines?
If you were using-- if you're
trying to do algorithms, yes.
That's a more reasonable model.
We're trying to prove things
about the computation.
And from that
standpoint, we want
to use as simple a
model as possible.
Trying to prove things using
random access computers
is possible.
It'd be very messy.
So that's why we don't
use random access machines
to prove the kinds
of things we're
going to be proving about
computation that are really
the meat and potatoes
of this course.
So I mean, there's
compelling reasons
why you would want to use a
simple model like a Turing
machine, but not a powerful
model like a random access
computer.
So somebody's asking me,
does the class time order n
log log n have any elements?
Yes, it has all the regular
languages, but nothing else.
Order n log log is it's
only the regular languages.
You have to go all the way
up to n log n before you
get something non-regular.
Someone's asking me are
we going to talk about how
the random access model works?
No.
That's beyond the
scope of this course,
outside of what we're
going to be doing.
We're going to talk
about Turing machines.
Not because we care so
much about Turing machines.
But I'm trying to prove
things about computation.
And the Turing machines
are a convenient vehicle
for doing that.
Our candle has burned out.
Why don't we return,
then, to the next slide.
So everybody come back.
So this answers one of the
questions I got on the chat.
What actually is the dependency
between multi-tape Turing
machines and one
tape Turing machines?
Can we bound that in general?
Yes, we can.
We're going to show that
converting a multi-tape Turing
machine to a one tape
Turing machine can, at most,
blow up the amount of time
that's necessary by squaring.
No, I acknowledge it's a lot.
But it still allows you--
but it's still small compared
with an exponential increase.
And we're going to be
focusing, in this course,
on things like the
difference between polynomial
and exponential, not
between the different--
not between the difference of--
not the difference between
n squared and n cubed.
That's going to be
less of a factor,
less of an issue for us.
So the way I'm
showing this theorem
is that if you have a
multi-tape Turing machine that
can do a language in a
certain amount of time,
then it's in the time complexity
class of that time bound
squared.
And the way I'm
just saying that is
because this is the bound that's
utilizing the one tape model.
So another way of saying
that is converting
multi-tape to one tape
squares the amount of time you
need at most.
So the way we're going
to prove that is simply
by going back and remembering
the conversion that we already
presented from
multi-tape to one tape.
And observe that if we
analyze that conversion,
it just ends up squaring
the amount of time
that the multi-tape used.
So why is that?
So if you remember,
let's just make
sure we're all together on this,
the way the single tape machine
S simulates the multi
tape Turing machine
M is that it takes the
contents of each of M's tapes,
up to the place where there's
infinitely many blanks.
Obviously you don't
store the infinite part.
But the active
portion of each of M's
tapes, you're going to
store them consecutively
in separate blocks on S's
tape, on S's only tape.
And now every time
M makes one move,
S has to scan its
entire tape to see
what's under each of the heads
and to do all the updating.
So to simulate one step
of M's computation,
S is going to use order of
t of n steps, where t of n
is the total running time
that M is going to use.
So why is t of m
steps coming up here?
Well, that's because you
have to measure how--
S is going to make a
scan across its tape.
How big can its tape be?
Well M, if it's trying to
use as much tape as possible,
can use, at most, t
of n tape on each of--
t of n cells on
each of its tapes.
So altogether,
they're just going
to be some constant number of
times t of n cells on S's tape.
Do you see that?
So each one of these is going
to be, at most, t of n long.
So this all together is going
to be order t of n long.
Because what can M do?
It could send its head out,
say the head on this tape
here, moving as fast as
possible to the right,
using as much tape as it can.
But you can only use t of
n cells in t of n time.
So this is going
to be order t of n.
So one step of
computation is going
to be t of n steps
on S's computation.
But M itself has t of n steps.
So it's going to be
t of n times t of n
for the total number
of steps that S
is going to end up using.
And that's where the
squaring comes from.
Similar results, I'm not going
to do lots of simulations
of one model by another.
I think that you'll
get the idea.
And you can, if
you're interested,
you can study those on your own.
But you can convert
multidimensional Turing
machines to one tape
Turing machines, one tape
ordinary linear--
one tape, one
dimensional machines.
And the bottom line
is that among all
of the reasonable
models, they're
all what are called
polynomially related if each
can simulate the other with,
at most, a polynomial overhead.
So if one of the machines
can use this t of n time,
the other machine
that's simulating it
would use t to the k
of n time for some k.
That's what it means
for the two machines
to be polynomially related.
And all reasonable
deterministic models
are polynomially related.
So as we've already seen, one
tape and multi-tape Turing
machines are
polynomially related,
because converting multi-tape
to one tape blows you up by,
at most, squaring.
So k equals 2 in this case.
Multidimensional
Turing machines,
again, polynomially related,
the random access machine,
which I'm not going to
define, but it's the machine
that you might
imagine-- you would,
I'm sure they must define in
some form in the algorithms
classes, polynomially related.
Cellular automata, which are
just arrays of finite automata
that can communicate with
each other, similarly.
All the reasonable
deterministic models,
again, classical
models, I'm not talking
about quantum computing,
are polynomially related.
So we are-- that kind
of justifies our choice
in picking one of
them, as long as we're
going to ask
questions which don't
depend upon the polynomial.
Let's then talk about the
class P. So the class P,
this is an important
definition for us.
This is the collection
of all languages
that you can do in time n to
the k for some k on a one tape
Turing machine.
Or as I've written
it over here, I
don't know if this notation
is unfamiliar to you,
but this is like just a big sum.
But here, it's a
big union symbol.
It's union over all values of
k of the time class n to the k.
So this is time n, union time
n squared, union time n cubed,
union time n to
the 4th, and so on.
We call these the polynomial
time decidable languages.
So we're going to be spending
a certain amount of effort
exploring this class P
and other similar classes.
Somebody's asking me
why is it a union.
I'm not sure how else
you would write it.
So if somebody-- if you have
a proposal for a different way
to write it, that's fine.
But this is k,
this is for all k.
I don't know-- if you only had
a limited finite number of k's,
you could just take
the biggest one.
But since it's for all k, you
need to write it as a union.
Now, I want to argue that the
class P is an important class.
And why has it had so
much impact on the subject
and in terms of
applications as well?
So one thing is
that the class P is
invariant for all reasonable
deterministic models.
What do I mean by that?
So we have defined the class P
in terms of these time classes
here, which, in
turn, are defined
in terms of the one tape model.
So we have defined P by using
one tape Turing machines.
Now if we had defined P in terms
of multi-tape Turing machines,
we get exactly the same
class, because one tape
and multi-tape Turing machines
are polynomially related
to one another.
And since we're taking the
union over all polynomials,
that polynomial difference
is going to wash out.
Similarly, we could
define P using
any of the other reasonable
deterministic models.
And we get exactly
the same class.
So in a sense, we
get back what we--
the situation that we had
in computability theory,
when the class of
decidable languages
didn't depend on
the choice of model.
Here, the class
P does not matter
depending upon the choice of
reasonable deterministic model.
And we also kind of, even in the
case of computability theory,
we have to stick with kind of
reasonable models that cannot
do an infinite amount
of work in one step.
I'm not going to define what
it means to be reasonable.
That's, in a sense,
an informal notion.
But among all of those
reasonable models,
you're going to get
the same class P.
The other thing that
makes P important
is that P roughly
corresponds to the problems
that you can solve in some
reasonable practical sense.
Now, not exactly, problems
that require n to the hundredth
time, you could argue cannot be
solved in any reasonable sense.
But if you think
about it, for example,
from the perspective
of cryptography,
cryptographic codes
that people come up with
are typically
designed to require,
or the hope is that they would
require an exponential amount
of effort to crack.
If someone found even an n
to the hundredth algorithm
to crack, that
would crack a code,
people would feel that
the code is not secure,
even though n to the
hundredth is still large.
So it's a rough kind of test.
But it's still used as
a kind of litmus test
for practical solvability
if you can solve it
in polynomial time.
You basically figured out
how to avoid large searches
if you can solve problems
in polynomial time.
We'll say more about that later.
But what I want
to bring out here
is that we have combined,
here in the class P, something
that's mathematically
nice, mathematically
elegant with something
that's practically relevant.
And when you have a
combination of the two,
then you know you have a winner.
Then you know how you
have a concept that's
going to make a difference.
And that's been true
for the class P.
This has been very influential
within and without the theory
of computation.
So let's look at an example.
Let's define a new language
we haven't seen before,
though it's similar
to procedures
that we've looked at before.
The PATH language,
which is where
I'm going to give you a graph
G, two nodes in the graph,
s and t, where I'm thinking
of G as a directed graph.
So directed means that the
connections between the nodes
in G are going to be directed.
And that they have
arrows on them.
They're not just
lines, but they have
an orientation with an arrow.
So G is a directed graph
that has a path from s to t
that respects the directions.
So such a-- I think I might
even have a picture here, yeah.
So imagine here,
here is your graph.
If you can see it,
there are little arrows
connecting the nodes.
And I want to know is
there a path from the node
s to the node t.
So that is a picture of
a problem, an instance
of a graph of a PATH problem.
And I want to find an
algorithm for that.
And I can show that there
is an algorithm that
operates in polynomial
time for this PATH problem.
And the algorithm, any of the
standard searching algorithms
would work here.
But let's just, for
completeness sake,
include the breadth-first
search algorithm
that we have explored
previously when
we talk about finite automata.
So we'll mark s.
And they'll keep repeating
until nothing new is marked.
And we'll mark all
of the nodes that
were reachable by a single arrow
from a previously marked node.
And then CFT is marked, After
you have marked everything
you can get to.
So you're going to mark--
let's see, pictorially, here
I think I have this indicated.
Yeah you're going to mark
all of the things that
are reachable from the start--
from the node s.
And then see, after you
can't mark anything new,
whether the node G is marked.
And if it is, you'll accept.
If it is not, you reject.
Now, we can analyze this, too.
And I'm not going to be
spending a lot of time
analyzing algorithms here.
But let's just do it
kind of this one time.
We're doing a bunch
of iterations here.
So we're going to be repeating
until nothing new is marked.
So each time we
mark something new,
we can only do that,
at most, n times.
At which point, we've
marked everything.
So the number of iterations
here is going to be, at most, n.
And now for each time
we mark something,
we have to look at all of
the previously marked nodes
and see which things they
point at to mark them too.
So this is going to be an
inner loop, which again,
has, at most, n iterations,
because it's going through all
of the previously marked nodes.
And then once we have that,
we can scan G to see--
to mark all of the new--
all of the nodes
which we have not yet
marked, whether they're
connected with a previously
marked node by an edge.
And I'm being generous here,
because I don't really care.
This can be done in, at most,
n squared steps on a one tape
Turing machine.
I'm not going to describe
the implementation.
But I'll leave it to
you as an exercise.
But this is straightforward.
So the total number
of steps here
would be n iterations times
n iterations times n squared.
So you're going to be, at most,
n to the 4th steps needed.
So this is a
polynomial algorithm.
And whether I ended
up with to the 4th,
or n to the 5th, or n
cubed, I don't really care.
Because I'm just trying
to illustrate that
the total is polynomial.
And that's all I'm going to
be typically asking you to do.
So to show polynomial time,
what I'll be asking you to do
is to show that each stage,
each stage of this algorithm,
should be clearly polynomial.
And that the total number
of stages, I'm sorry,
this should say stages
here, should be polynomial.
So each stage is polynomial.
And after you're doing
all the iterations,
the total number of stages that
are executed is polynomial.
And so therefore, all together,
the total running time,
the total number of steps,
is going to be polynomial.
So that's the way we would
write up polynomial algorithms
in this class.
So let's see if there's
any questions here.
I don't want to get too
far ahead of people.
Let's see.
Yes, in this theorem, I'm
talking about one tape Turing
machines, because we're
defining everything in terms
of one tape Turing machines.
But now, at this
point, when we're
talking about polynomial
time, my analysis
is based on one tape
Turing machines.
But in general, you could use
any reasonable deterministic
model on which to carry
out your analysis,
because they're all
polynomially equivalent.
So from the perspective
of coming up
with showing that a problem is
in polynomial time, is in P,
you can use any of
the models that you
wish that for convenient.
Oh, that's a good question.
What is n, thank you for
asking that question.
n is always going to
be reserved to indicate
the length of the input.
So here, n is going to be
when we encode G, s, and t.
And here, also, I
haven't said this,
but I'm assuming that the
encoding that you're using
is also somehow reasonable.
I think we'll talk
a little bit more
about that in the
next lecture, which is
going to be after the midterm.
But you can cause problems
if you intentionally
tried to come up with
nasty encodings, which
will represent things with
unnecessarily many characters.
But if you try to be
reasonable, then just
use any one of those
encodings, and you'll be fine.
So yeah, so n is the length
of the representation
of the input.
Let's see.
Someone's trying to
dig into the actual
how this is running here.
Scan G to mark all y
where xy is an edge.
I'm saying that you can
do it in n squared steps.
If you have x, you can mark it
in a certain place on the tape.
And then as you're going
to every other node,
every other edge,
you can go back
and compare x with the x
of the edge and then see--
and then find the y.
I mean, it's just going to be
too messy to talk about here.
I mean, I'll leave it
as an exercise to you.
I'm not going to try to fumble
my way through explaining
why you can do this
in n squared steps.
But it's not hard.
You guys are all really
hardcore algorithms folks.
You want to know the
algorithms for this,
I'm not going to do that, sorry.
High level picture here.
If you want-- if you want to
look at detailed analyses,
this is not the
right course for you.
Can k equal n?
What is k?
No, if you're talking about
this k here, k cannot equal n.
We're not looking at n to the n.
These are all fixed k, it's
like n squared, n cubed,
but not n to the n is it going
to be an exponential bound.
And so that's not going to be
included within this union.
So we're near the
end of the hour.
I'm going to introduce one last
language here, called HAMPATH.
And the HAMPATH problem is--
I'm going to ask now,
again, for a path from s
to t, but now a
different kind of path,
one that goes through every
node of G along the way.
So I'm looking for
a path that goes,
that hits every node of
G, not just the shortest,
most direct path.
But in a sense, the most
indirect path, the longest path
that goes through from s to
t that visits everything else
along the way.
A path of that kind, that
hits every node of the graph
is called a Hamiltonian path.
Because the
mathematician Hamilton
studied those and made some
definitions about that.
I'm not going to--
I don't actually know
the history there.
But I just know they're
called Hamiltonian paths.
So here's a picture.
I want to get from s to t.
But I want to sort of pick up
everything else along the way.
So as you remember,
the PATH problem itself
can be solved in P. And
what I'd like to know,
can this simple
modification, where
I'm asking you to visit
everything else along the way,
is that problem also in P?
And I'm going to pose this
as a check-in for you.
But actually, before
I get to that,
let me give you an
algorithm for HAMPATH
that doesn't work to show it's
in P, because it's exponential.
So here's an
algorithm for HAMPATH,
where let's m the
number of nodes in G.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to try every possible path
in G and see if it's actually
works as a Hamiltonian
path, and accept if it is.
And then if all paths
fail, then I'll reject.
So I'm going to try every
possible routing through G.
If you want to think
about it, think
of m as every possible
permutation of the nodes of G.
And then you're going to
see whether that's actually
constitutes a path in G
that takes you from s to t
and goes through
all of the nodes.
So this algorithm would work.
This would give you
a correct algorithm
for the HAMPATH problem.
The problem is,
the difficulty is
that there are so many
possible paths that it's
going to take you an
exponential number of steps
to execute this algorithm.
It's not a polynomial
time algorithm,
because there are
many possible paths
that you could go through.
If you're looking at it
with a very crude bound,
but you really can't
improve that significantly,
there would be m
factorial, which
is going to be much greater than
2 to the m paths of length m.
So the algorithm is going
to run for exponential time,
and not polynomial time.
So my question for
you is, I'm going
to pose it as a
check-in problem,
is whether you could
actually do this problem
in polynomial time.
So why don't you
think about that
as I'm setting up the question?
So take the HAMPATH problem,
just like the PATH problem,
which I described with
that marking algorithm,
but now you want to hit
every node along the way,
can you show that
problem as solvable in P?
And there's a whole
range of possibilities
here where either the
answer is yes, you
can see what the polynomial
time algorithm is to definitely
no, where you can prove there
is no such polynomial time
algorithm.
And I'll put this is the
check-in for you and see--
I'm curious to see
what you come up with.
Most people are
getting it wrong.
Well, wrong, I don't you know--
I'm not clear what
wrong is here.
OK, are we done?
Please check something.
I see a few of you
have not answered.
But the poll is running out.
OK, time is up.
So in fact, as I think many of
you know, but not all of you,
this is an unsolved problem.
This is a very famous
unsolved problem,
which is equivalent to
the P versus NP problem
that we're going to be
talking about very soon,
which, among other things,
would be worth a million dollars
if you solve it.
So for those of you who
have answered a or e,
please talk to me after lecture.
And maybe we can
work on it together.
No, so yeah, I think
most people would
believe that the answer is no.
But no one knows how to
prove it at this time.
So I'm interested
in the folks who
have come up with what
they think are solutions.
And I should say that
there are some folks who
believe that there might be
other outcomes besides just
a simple no.
Which might be
proven eventually.
So we're going to
talk more about this.
But this is the answer to
the question, just for your--
just to make sure you
understand is that it's
an unsolved problem right now.
So we don't know.
Definitely yes
and definitely no,
at least according to the
state of knowledge of which I'm
aware, are not correct answers.
But any of the others,
well, who knows?
So I think that's the end of
what I had to say for today.
We covered complexity
theory as an introduction,
looked at different
possible models,
focused on the one
tape model, introduced,
based on the one tape
model, these complexity
classes, the class P. And we
showed an example of this PATH
problem being in P. Talked also
about this HAMPATH problem,
which we'll talk about
more after the midterm.
OK, so I'll stick
around for a few minutes
if you have any
further questions.
Otherwise, so let me
just take questions here.
Somebody is asking me
about my personal opinion
on P versus NP.
My personal opinion on P versus
NP is that P is not equal to NP
and that we will
prove it someday.
When I was a graduate
student back in the mid '70s,
I thought it would
be solved by now.
And in fact, I made a bet with
Len Adleman, who I subsequently
ended up becoming the
A of the RSA code,
that we would solve
it by the year 2000.
And I bet what was
then a lot of money
for me, which was an ounce of
gold, which I didn't end up--
which I did end up paying
off to Len in the year 2000.
So I'm not making any more bets.
But I still believe
that it will be solved.
Hopefully I'll get a
chance to see the solution.
I spend a lot of time
thinking about it myself.
Obviously, I haven't solved
it, otherwise we would know.
But hopefully somebody will.
I'm gettings asked
a question here
that's kind of an
interesting question,
but I don't really know
I'm sure I understand it.
What's the largest possible
runtime of a decidable problem?
What is the largest
decidable runtime?
So anything that I
can describe can be--
there are going to be
algorithms that run for longer.
You can define an algorithm.
You can define a runtime,
which would, in a sense,
beats all other runtimes.
So that any runtime is
going to be dominated
by that extremely slow runtime.
But it's not something
that one can describe.
I can describe it to you
by mathematical procedure.
But it's not going to
be something like 2
to the 2 to the n.
Somebody's here proposing a
solution to the HAMPATH problem
by presuming polynomial time.
Why is the following flawed?
If s goes through all
nodes and ends up at t,
Well, s we're not--
you mean, I presume
you mean starting at s,
if we end up going through
all nodes and end at t,
the proposal is a
little complicated here.
Basically, if I can
try to rephrase it,
you want to try to--
from every possible
node, you want
to try to calculate a path
to t and also a path from s
to that node.
And you can do that
for all possible nodes.
But there's no way to
really combine them
into a single path
that visits all.
Solving for each node
separately is not
going to do the trick, because
you have to somehow combine
all that information into a
single path, just one path that
goes from s to t and visits all
the other nodes along the way.
And that that is not--
I don't see what
your proposal, how
that's going to actually work.
AUDIENCE: Professor Sipser.
A question on the--
we were kind of talking
about earlier, what
we talked about today was
defined for the one tape Turing
machines, correct?
MICHAEL SIPSER: Yep
AUDIENCE: So and you said we
could apply for the multi-tape
ones, but are--
I don't know if we talked
about earlier, if something
is accepted by the
one tape machine,
can it be applied to the
multi-tape Turing machine
and vice versa?
Are they interchangeable
like that?
MICHAEL SIPSER: Well
they're interchangeable only
in the sense that the amount of
time that you would need-- it's
a different machine.
If you have a multi-tape Turing
machine for some language,
you can convert it to a
one tape Turing machine
using the procedure that we
described earlier in the term.
And you'll get a
different machine.
It's going to run for a
different amount of time
by using that procedure.
The point is that the amount of
time that the one tape Turing
machine is going
to run for is not
that much worse than the
multi-tape Turing machine's
time.
So if the multi-tape Turing
machine's time was n cubed,
the one tape Turing machine's is
going to be the square of that.
So it's going to
be n to the 6th.
But it's not going to be--
going from multi-tape
to one tape
is not going to convert you
from polynomial to exponential.
That's the only point
I'm trying to make.
It's going to convert
from one polynomial
to a somewhat bigger polynomial.
But it's still going to
leave you polynomial.
I don't-- you don't seem--
I can't see your face.
AUDIENCE: No, I guess my opinion
is just, especially when we
were talking about earlier,
when you were bringing it up,
it just seemed like you
could just turn anything
to a multi tape Turing machine
and completely cut the time
out.
If I had like
something in n log n,
if I did it in the
multi-tape Turing machine,
I have it in big O of
n, you know what I mean?
It just seemed like the
multi-tape was so much more
powerful.
But then I guess not, with the
explanations and the models
we were talking about today.
MICHAEL SIPSER:
Yeah, I would not
say-- the multi-tape Turing
machines are still pretty
limited in their capabilities.
And don't forget, when you have
a multi-tape Turing machine,
you have only a fixed
number of tapes.
I mean, you can also define
variations of multi-tape Turing
machines that have an increasing
number of tapes as the input,
either under program control,
it can launch new tapes.
Or it could just have
more tapes depending
upon the size of the input, that
would also be a possibility.
That's not the model
that we have defined.
But you could define
a model like that.
But as long as the
total amount of work
being done by the
machine at any step
s going to be a
polynomial amount of work,
then you can convert it to
a one tape Turing machine
with only a polynomial
increase in the bound.
You want to be
careful of machines--
one thing I meant to say
but didn't say, so here
would be an unreasonable
model, which you might
think of as a plausible model.
But it's not going to
be a reasonable model
from our standpoint.
And that would be a
model, for example,
that can do full precision,
say, integer arithmetic
with a unit cost per operation.
So each operation
counts as costs 1.
But I'm going to
allow you to do,
for example, addition
and multiplication.
The thing that's bad about that,
in terms of being unreasonable,
is that after k step,
each time you do a step,
you could double the size of
the integer by squaring it.
After k steps, you can have an
integer, which is 2 to the k
long.
And now, doing
operations there is
going to involve an
exponential amount of work,
even in any reasonable sense.
In a theoretical sense, and
also in a practical sense.
A model that operates
like that is not
going to be able to convert
to a one tape Turing machine
with only a polynomial
increase, because it's
doing an exponential
amount of work
potentially within a
polynomial number of steps.
So that's within a linear
number of steps, within n steps.
So that's an example of an
unreasonable deterministic
model.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
MICHAEL SIPSER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So I'm just curious,
some idea just occurred to me.
I guess if you have an Oracle
Turing machine, basically
just so that you could look at
a Turing machine description
and decide whether
it's a decider or not,
then it'd be a little bit
interesting to think about what
happens if you look at all--
if you have a description
of a pair of the Turing
machine and an input
string, then you
can look at for all
size n descriptions
of a pair, what's the most
steps that it takes for such
a machine to convert it.
So then you'd have combined
Turing machine and input string
descriptions, where
you could look
at what's the longest
it takes to convert.
I don't know.
It's just a random
thought that occurred.
MICHAEL SIPSER: Yeah, so we
actually-- we're going to-- we
will talk about Oracle Turing
machines later on in the term.
These are machines
that have access
to sort of free information.
And that actually
turns out to be--
there's some
interesting things you
can say about what
happens when you're
providing a machine with, in
a sense, information for free.
That you might otherwise want
to charge it for actually
computing that information.
But let's just say
we're going to allow
it to get that information
without being charged.
And then how does that
affect the complexity
of other problems, for example?
And so we will talk
about that later.
But too much of, I
think, of a digression
at this moment to try
to define all that.
But happy to chat with
you about it on Piazza
if you want to raise
a question there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MICHAEL SIPSER:
Sure, no problem.
Somebody's asking me about
strategies for solving the P
versus NP problem.
We will talk also talk
about that a little later
in the term as well.
But clearly, it seems beyond the
reach of our present techniques
to be able to prove that
some problems really
take a long time.
Like that Hamiltonian
path problem,
it seems like there's
nothing really
you can do with that
significantly better
than trying all
possibilities as I
described in that exponential
algorithm on the last slide.
But how do you prove that?
Nobody knows.
So lots of people have
tried, including yours truly.
I mean, I've spent a lot
of time thinking about it.
Haven't succeeded with it.
But there is somebody, I
think, someday, somebody
will come up with the new idea
that's needed to solve it.
But it's going to clearly take
some sort of a breakthrough,
some sort of a new idea.
It's not just going to be
a combination of existing
ideas, existing methods.
I think we're about
10 minutes past.
A few of you are still here.
I'm going to say
goodbye to you folks.
And shortly, I'm going to
join my TAs for our weekly TA
meeting.
So see you guys.
Thanks for being here.